ready breathing technique i've got a new
breathing coach
by the power of castle gay skull i mean
hate school god damn it i messed it up
but we're gonna keep going it was just a
freudian slip don't look too much into
it there's nothing going on here in my
brain that was thinking gay and then it
came out okay it's just a slip of the
tongue it happens to every closet
homosexual i mean normal guy anyway how
you doing
casey is that gonna get this banned yeah
it's not gonna okay should we just
but did you ever see uh nor mcdonald on
like conor o'brien he was saying like in
his memoir or whatever that he's a
deeply closeted homosexual and and conan
be like wait you're gay and he's like no
i said he's deeply closeted
it's amazing yeah because it's there's
no resp i like jokes that trick you into
responding the only way that would be
appropriate it's like you're telling me
you're gay but also that you're deeply
closeted so he would never admit that
he's gay that's called a rhetorical
trick we're gonna go right into hella
rhetorical let's examine that just
kidding you know we actually were going
to go straight to
a new segment i'm calling hot chick of
the week now we had this absolute beauty
submitted to us
earlier this week and i thought wow what
is her name what is her number i want to
get into contact with her
look at those cheeks
look at those lips and uh according to
her she's all natural so
they don't make them like they used to
huh what's going on here what's going on
is this actually
this is me dressed as a woman all right
i'm going to come clean i am going to
come clean yes now you guys know what i
do on the weekend so when you come in
and say hey how you know sup fool what's
going on what'd you do this weekend one
part that i've been leaving out is the
fact that i dress up like a woman for
fun i'd smash
uh you and every other guy
on planet earth i think it's safe to say
this picture came up somebody actually
sent it to me they were scrolling you
know it's from 2017
when i was on
50 central and a couple sketches i would
do
markeisha this is actually a funny
little cultural commentary i think
i have no problem dressing up like a
girl for laughs what you do see is that
it's a lot of work putting on nails
doing the hair and makeup you know
getting on a dress even just doing it to
this degree
it's like you know to do makeup
effectively
you're either hiring somebody like
there's a couple times i'm like i want
to do sketch as a girl that'd be funny
and then i'm like well then i would have
to like do makeup every time if i want
to look stunningly gorgeous like i do in
this picture
and it's more work that i want to do but
i was going to say when they came to us
and had some sketch ideas
i was the only white person on the cast
the the other black men on the cast
the other cast members who were men were
black i should say
they
in no way wanted to dress up as women
and i don't know if that's a broader
cultural thing
or
like dave chappelle influenced people to
do that because remember he was on
inside the actor's studio talking about
how
there's like this notion that
when a black man gets too famous
they emasculate you by putting you in a
dress
and they try to get him to do that i
know it's gonna be hilarious on you know
chappelle's show and he's like no man i
don't do that um
everyone has different cultures and
different boundaries and so it's like
that would make sense to me especially
if you have if you knew you were gonna
get a lot of [ __ ] for it or whatever i
can see doing that but i for one don't
have those kind of hang ups so i jumped
at the opportunity if you google 50 cent
steals another man's girl on youtube i'm
not saying we're gonna watch it here but
you will see me
one of the sketches
that i did dressed as a girl as
markeisha
is on youtube and i love it
one of my favorite sketches from that
show
and jasmine brown's dressed up as a guy
and she's
hilarious like when i show people how
jasmine brown actually looks in real
life compared to the character that she
does reggie the mechanic
they're shocked
okay now that we got that out of the way
that i am in fact a beautiful woman
we can go on to the liver king meme of
the week i thought this is hilarious and
it doesn't even involve the liver king
it just involves
donald trump talking about him
[Music]
i didn't know that i just i don't even
know for the first time
[Music]
you letting me know that i don't know
for the first time what donald trump
says
the caption at the top is what sets up
that joke
me
you know he claims to be natty but he's
obviously not he makes veiled references
to his ped use all the time some people
actually are saying his abs are fake too
this guy has a total fraud man you have
to check it out the cashier checking me
out
uh that's the first time i'm hearing
about this
love it it's so perfect and uh and i
just always find that i you do stuff
like that you start going off on the
things that you care about
and forget that not many other people do
care about that and you're putting
people in a weird position i've never
done that right that's crazy me make
people uncomfortable in situations by
talking about things they're bored from
okay let's get into
[Laughter]
casey's like nope never happened to me
man that's crazy dude yeah you only talk
about stuff that everybody's um into
sup fool
so i
i saw this the other day and thought it
was worthy talking about first of all
luke thomas
he's a guy who i really respect as far
as
you know one mma expert to another um he
breaks down the x's and o's and i think
you know you have guys like brendan i
always actually love hearing brendan's
insight
into
the world of mma and how certain things
work that as a fighter or
you know as a guy who's been behind the
scenes or even a guy who
has
so many relationships in mma anytime i
hear something that he tells me in
private about some of his experiences
it's always super interesting and i
think
brendan has this
you know sort of
uh you know editorial opinion based
hot take
you know lane of mma where he's been
there and he's also commentating on it i
love hearing stuff like that then you
got guys but he's not going to
necessarily you know analyze a whole
fight and break down the x's and o's of
each kick but guys like um
luke thomas and there's a few others
um
that
a lot of it's above my pay grade you
know but i do learn from it i don't
necessarily get everything that he's
talking about um like dan hardy you know
that's what i was gonna say yeah like
super
intellectual x's and o's like stuff that
you really
it's impossible to see unless you have
his level of correct experience and also
intelligence to be able to break it down
that way yeah and he also like i
realized
it's a youtube video i listen to a lot
of youtube videos and i'm like i can't
listen to this because i'll be totally
lost you know you actually have to look
at the graphic and like watch his
replays like that but
i love that there's guys out there doing
this luke thomas is another one where i
feel like he's got that
analysis of fights
down where he's looking at the x's and
o's and it's like man he is good at his
job
now is he a guy i go to for diet
expertise not necessarily i'm not saying
that he doesn't know what he's talking
about but he made an interesting point
here that i'm going to agree and also
disagree with so let's run that tape
about a dude i've never heard of steak
and eggs diet dude all of these [ __ ]
diets they all do the same thing
they all do the same thing keto paleo
whatever the [ __ ] you want they all do
the same thing time restricted eating
whatever
all they do
is shorten the window you can eat or the
kinds of amounts you can eat or the
certain types of food you can eat in
such a way as to reduce calories
that's it they have different mechanisms
of finding the same answer but they all
work the same yeah to me like when
someone's like a carnivore diet it's
like i i don't really understand what
the problem is with having a
well-balanced diet and it's someone
who's had digestive problems like real
digestive problems where i've had to go
to [ __ ] hospital for him that seems
like relatively crazy to me so i can't
speak to this gentleman's particular
worldview
but what i would humbly
ask you to consider is that all of these
diets work the same basically find which
one works best for you
and
enjoy someone's ass there we go so
obviously he's speaking directly to
brendan
which i didn't think about before the
carnivore no but the carnivore is pretty
popular and he could actually very well
be speaking at brenda they talk about
exercise sometimes um they communicate
back and forth
what i was gonna say is he's making a
really good broad point which is if
you're trying to lose weight if that's
the objective and the only objective
then putting yourself in a caloric
deficit is the only end goal right
because you can eat lots of healthy food
you know you could be eating a chicken
broccoli diet and in theory be in a
caloric surplus which isn't going to
help you lose weight although you might
turn around and go
i'm eating a hundred percent healthy and
i never have a cheat meal any time how
can i possibly be gaining weight now to
me
to casey and some if you're into fitness
my assumption is that you know that like
the fundamental basic idea that a
caloric deficit is the only way to lose
weight whether that's from
diet exclusively or from exercise
exclusively or a combination of the two
and i'd realize that sentence might not
even make sense but i mean like if
you're going i'm going to set my you
know calories at maintenance
for
you know my sort of just general
activity level my bmr
and then increase or decrease like okay
then i'm going to decrease the calories
because i don't want to do extra extra
exercise or i'm going to increase my
exercise because i don't want to reduce
my calories anymore or figuring out you
know how to balance both of those but
you just got to
burn more calories than you take in
whether that's just through your body's
natural processes or
uh from additional exercise and movement
throughout the day but if it's not the
deliberate exercise you know walking or
even you know just sort of standing
right casey's got this dope ass standing
desk sometimes it just pops up my whoa
put the hydraulics on that bad boy huh
and
you know those are the only mechanisms i
take for granted sometimes if people
know this i was talking with one of my
clients i'm not going to throw them
under the bus but
you know who you are and
he
i've noticed that he has more of an
obsession like his idea of eating
healthy is like i'm gonna reduce fats
i'm gonna eat chicken instead of this
and like people have these foods that
they latch on to like this is eating
healthy to me
and it's often at least partially
mistaken or if the objective is to lose
body fat
they're not looking at it in the context
of like this balance this checkbook and
i like to encourage people to use a
weekly check book balancing to look at
your total calories because
it's going to be different every day you
know you're going to maybe cheat one day
and then you want to borrow the next day
rather than feeling like every day i
have to be perfect or i'm off my diet so
i like to
get people to think in terms of a weekly
caloric balance because it allows you
some creativity and flexibility and
differentiating you know your calories
on different days where you might be
exercising more etc
he
i realize
didn't
know that you can only lose weight in a
caloric deficit
he's trained for many years he was even
around bodybuilders growing up and in
his 20s and part of like the training
that he likes is that style that he kind
of learned when he was younger but i
didn't realize
he
didn't understand that basic like he
wants to lose fat but he's like oh i
didn't realize you have to count it and
actually be in a deficit and didn't
understand how you could calculate that
baseline and specifically he goes
well i know the fda recommends 2 000
calories a day
and so i was just looking at and i go oh
of course this is a government entity
saying this
so it's like the food pyramid you know
it's like wait i'm not supposed to eat
11 servings of grains every day what but
obviously these things are bunk but i
also take that for granted because this
is government propaganda essentially
about fitness that you know helps
certain industries and doesn't actually
look out for an individual's best
interests as far as health
2000 calories is meaningless
right because
that doesn't even say man or woman or
you know i'm 250 pounds
uh
you could be a 125 pound male we have
the same caloric
uh
requirements
no we would at least be you know the
easy way to answer that is i need twice
as many calories for my weight
there's
all sorts of variability based on height
weight age uh activity all these things
and it's been flattened out to 2000 cal
now that's not a bad starting point but
like i would lose a lot of weight but a
small girl would either
keep her same size or get fatter
potentially you know if you're around a
hundred pounds you can easily gain
weight on 2000 calories a day
so
that basic notion of like what's your
caloric starting point that's a
not something i guess you can take for
granted so go to caloriecalculator.net
go to myfitnesspal
estimate your bmr and that's your basal
metabolic rate if you were to sleep all
day essentially lay down that's 70
calories your body would be burning and
it's probably more than you think you
know your body requires calories just to
get through the day um
so
that's going to button up me talking
about like yeah you've got to figure out
that number and then figure out how many
calories you're eating it's easier to
measure actually the calories that
you're
putting in your body then you're
expelling even the
most complex instruments to do that
aren't quite accurate but
measuring caloric intake is far more
accurate because whatever you can
measure
you know in a gram of something you can
just
scale that right we know how many
calories are in a gram of any food that
you're eating
where he's wrong
where i'm going to push back a little
bit and obviously you know anytime a
guy's like oh diets are all the same and
it's like okay show me how you got the
six percent body fat
not to dislike thomas but he is
overweight
right just visually speaking
uh you can
see it through his clothes it doesn't
look bad he looks
good for his age but he doesn't look
like a guy who's ever done any sort of
extreme dieting to get under 10 body fat
let alone like six or five
when you start to talk to those kind of
guys like kino body or greg ducette or
any bot you'll see that they have their
own little tricks for doing so
especially if they're like selling a
program it's often like they have their
hacks for getting down there they have
an understanding of that process of
getting ripped and it's not just
well any diet is going to do it's all
just calorie deficit okay
on top of a calorie deficit what's going
to make you most full right a carnivore
diet and or a steak and eggs diet is
going to make you very full and satiated
and also
reduce the risk of you overeating
because it's very hard to overeat just
steak and eggs without any sort of
carbohydrate so the main thing i think
that people are drawn to with keto
number one you see rapid results because
in part you're not going to retain as
much water when you're not eating
carbohydrates and specifically processed
carbohydrates because you eat a bag of
chips or crackers all that dry processed
carbohydrate
inside your body is going to make you
want to drink a lot more water you know
because normally you're eating
carbohydrates in fruits and vegetables
in the wild as a neanderthal
when that's not present
um you know or all these foods also have
a lot of salt too so you're gonna be
retaining water from excessive sodium
consumption
these things make a difference to your
appearance how you feel your motivation
and also
when
you
you know
say things like oh man that's going to
be terrible my gi tract lots of people
have
you know enormous amounts of trouble
eating normal carbohydrates too like and
i would say
having done some of these diets before
you know my bowel movements are way
shittier
when i eat a bunch of carbs right
i just they're they're softer they're
more unpredictable whatever it just i've
actually counter-intuitively there's
this narrative out there that eating
meat all the time is necessarily
going to
mess your stomach up and give you
diarrhea or something but that's just
not
my experience and i think the experience
of a lot of people and then
the last most important thing is it
actually does make a difference
to your long-term health when you see
these carnivorous diets these high
protein if you have a problem if you're
pre-diabetic if you suffer from insulin
insensitivity because you've been eating
a lot of carbohydrates
and specifically processed carbs or
simple carbs in the form of sugar and
candy on stuff
doing a low carb diet could potentially
reset that and alter the course of your
health so there's a reason to do that
and a reason to at least
try it out and consider this idea and
consider you know the fact that you
might be insulin insensitive because you
eat too many carbohydrates
all right
and also like just you know he just
generally offers no insight into like
it's all the same man
okay
it's all the same but you know
getting to a caloric deficit with high
protein doesn't allow you to maintain a
lot more muscle versus a you know
achieving a caloric deficit for example
by only eating brown rice all day
not really going to work is it as far as
retaining the maximum amount of muscle
dude i just gotta say
larry wheels
he's quitting steroids and
this means that i will be on more
steroids than larry wheels moving
forward
and also outlifting him in every single
major lift on the planet so
i'm not gonna play this video but he was
this is like big news in the fitness
industry larry wheels if you don't know
larry wheels
get out from under that rock you've been
living under and
watch a youtube video
google his name the dude's tremendously
strong and anabolics are one part of
that but from what he's disclosed i
don't think he even takes absurd doses
and also i think that's a mis
understanding of how even steroids work
is like you can't take enough steroids
to get as strong as larry wheels he's
done like a 500 pound
seated press a 450 pound standing press
that was relatively strict
these numbers are so insane like
you know think of the biggest
bodybuilder you know even that he's
going to be way stronger than they are
even though he may not look as big
in some senses like he has many world
records in raw bench deadlift i'm not
sure about squat but certainly his total
i've seen him do like a nine plate
deadlift or like a 900 pound dead lifted
zoo although some of the plates don't
weigh that much
so
you know but he's he's essentially
insanely strong and one of the strongest
people of all time right um
and so
steroids helped that
but
you know naturally you look at a view of
him when he's like 14 or 15 he clearly
has the genetics and the muscle bellies
and the inserts
of a guy who's
could probably do tremendous things
naturally and i think that was one of
the reasons that he started taking
steroids in the first place as he
described being young and like seeing oh
i'm already like 15 and benching 405
naturally like i would i'm within
striking distance of some of these power
lifting records and of course that's
going to motivate you to be like all
right i'm going to take it to the next
level and actually instead of being like
i'm the strongest natty in the world
which turns out nobody gives a [ __ ]
about he wants to be just the strongest
guy in the world
you've seen him do a bunch of different
stuff over the years
because of injuries and unlike somebody
like callum von moger
who sort of
seemingly has succumbed to his injuries
or didn't pivot into something else
because he'd get an injury and
you know maybe he increased the partying
or didn't find another outlet
larry wheels has suffered frequent
injuries but seemingly always got back
on the horse and was doing something he
switched to arm wrestling he tried a
bodybuilding he would redirect his goals
and he's had this goal of a thousand
pound deadlift that he says in the video
that he still ultimately wants to do but
the big announcement is he's getting off
steroids now even that's a misnomer
because
he's still taking trt i hate when people
blur the lines between injectable
testosterone and steroids you are
injecting an anabolic steroid into your
body
it's an exogenous substance that's been
put in your body you're on steroids now
you can argue about how strong that dose
is but ultimately it's the same thing
because you're taking 600 milligrams
right you're on steroids but also not
200 it's not steroids but the dose that
he talks about actually the window is
like 70 to 175 is what he says in the
video
is considered trt but ultimately if your
true goal is testosterone replacement
you'd be looking at your blood levels
and achieving a certain blood
concentration of testosterone i believe
he's taking 175.
that's going to be a huge dip from what
i understand uh from what he had
normally been taking
here's the competitive angle that i
think he's found listening to the video
he goes i want to see how much i can do
natural or not on steroid no he's going
to be on trt but you get the idea
i think he's a guy who's motivated by
competition in any sense and that's
another difference between him and
callum
calamano competed as a bodybuilder but i
think he was more interested in just the
sort of like the fame career path
because he got into acting you know
he trained a lot but it was less clear
to me that he sort of had an objective
numerical way to evaluate himself
as a guy
you know and to compete with yourself
but i think larry wheels is a great case
study and a guy who's like what can i do
next to improve myself and get better at
when this fails or i can't do this one
thing can't do power lifting i'm going
to go do arm wrestling and he got really
into that and i don't care if people
quit their stuff right do it for two
years or a year you don't have to do
something for the rest of your life uh
just because you start it
right
um
it's a way for him knowing he's a
competitor knowing that that he finds
satisfaction and purpose and meaning in
that then you have to find any way to
keep doing that
and so
even though you're going to have to take
this step back and this is now a broader
metaphor for like when you're on
steroids it's hard to get off
many guys have experienced this and this
is one of the warnings up front of like
you know
don't
get on unless you can
right now deal with the reality that at
some point you're gonna have to get off
or take less right you can't blast trend
for the rest of your life you're gonna
die um
and that's been proven you know guys who
do stupid things like that like blast
trend for seven years is actually one of
the things that causes cancer or just
even jumping to trend these really
strong compounds my advice is always
like hey ramp up do the safest minimum
effective dose and work from there
because at some point you're gonna have
to get off
a lot of people would just look at the
fact that hey i'm not as strong oh my
god my muscles are smaller oh my god
this thing i don't feel is good right if
you set this really high bar he's
reframing it
and i always talk about that you have to
reframe things and go okay yeah okay i
can't do the thousand pound deadlift
right now or i can't be the strongest
i've ever been in my life but i can be
the strongest i've ever been on trt
without all this stuff so
take that use it for your own life
because i think that's one of the most
important things
in one's own happiness and satisfaction
in life is reframing things you know
instead of sitting there thinking about
all the things that you don't have all
the money you don't have or all the food
you don't have or all the
whatever it's this attitude of gratitude
versus entitlement
and
saying you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
do the best with what i have that's a
healthy attitude to take to anything
yes this is an episode of sesame street
um
i'm going to jump down i'm going to come
back to bros sands academy in a second
because it's been serious this is all
going to be super serious
saucy or not we haven't done one of
those in a while because you know what i
realized i don't really like looking at
guys too seriously who's on steroids or
not um
i enjoy doing mock
saucy or knots which we will continue in
the coming weeks
jesse james west is one of the most
well-known young fitness influencers in
the game makes a lot of content and
somebody i only thought about him
because i never thought he was on
steroids and then somebody
sent me
the question what do you think about
jesse james uh you think he's think he's
natty or not he's from what i understand
preparing for a competition when you see
him here
looking very ripped
he looks like he's sub 10 body fat uh
the lighting's great the editing on the
photo is fantastic so he's primed he's
dry to look as ripped as possible now i
don't look at him and get the steroid
look but i think this is where a lot of
people
look at a guy and they correlate being
shredded with being on steroids when
nothing could be further from the case
steroids do not make you shredded a
caloric deficit long term on top of
a decent amount of muscle makes you look
shredded he has a good base he trains
natty and he trains hard from what i can
ascertain and he has enough muscle so
that when he gets under 10 body fat he
doesn't just look like
uh you know he's anorexic right because
you can if you get too skinny he had no
muscle okay then you just look like a
marathon runner or a cyclist or
something like that
i look at that and i go no he's just
ripped right nothing about his physique
seems like it couldn't be achievable
naturally by a 20-something year old man
who's very disciplined about his
training and his diet
so
apparently the person asking was having
a debate with their partner about this
so it is up for debate and people
speculate it
on it all the time but i would use this
as a lesson to go
the dude's not on st i just and also his
personality he doesn't seem like the
kind of risk taker reckless person
that's my main gauge for this kind of
stuff i'm reckless
i go that looks interesting i'm going to
try it and then worry about the
consequences later or weigh things out
just kind of go like i'm going to learn
through self-experimentation
he strikes me as a much more calculated
guy who would be scared he's scared to
fail and he's also scared to get hooked
on drugs and he's also
scared to have that negative reputation
you know he's a kind of he wants to be
the good guy that's that's my read on
his persona you know it's like a logan
paul type guy
but less edgy if you can imagine no i
like you know logan paul versus jake
paul
jake i believe would at some point like
as a prank or something like that take
steroids but
you know guys like this it's like
they've they feel like they've got too
much writing and it's just not worth it
for what you know why would it take
steroids to comp you like to compete in
some shitty show
that's not where he's making his bread
and butter what do you think casey does
this guy look
on steroids or not i don't [ __ ] know
who am i i'd say no right but what's
your name like you don't even have to
analyze it what's your impression when
you look at this guy's physique he
doesn't look so
jacked that he looks like juicy yeah
yeah because what i look for is
when you really lean and your shoulders
are still huge that's kind of a giveaway
right he has a nice torso he's got nice
packs but yeah nothing there looks like
that's out of the ordinary when you see
a really ripped guy with like huge traps
and
medial delts
specifically that's probably one of the
biggest indicators of like you know
your androgen receptors
are being flooded by exogenous hormones
yeah so
yeah i look at this and i go
for everybody wanting to know how it
looks to be ripped think about him in a
shirt he's not going to look huge but
when you strip away that body fat when
you get under 10 body fat every single
person
looks good around 10 body fat i defy you
to show me somebody who looks better at
20 body fat than they do at 10 body fat
doesn't exist
um except for me i look equally hot at
all body fat percentages it's a fact so
real quick i just wanted to say for
everybody out there who
keeps commenting on the channel
oh mark hasn't done kratom this week
like i heard he's off it he's sick of it
there's all these rumors out there that
i'm no longer taking credit i'm no
longer taking kratom
those are all false okay i just want to
let you know from my heart i am still
taking happy hippo kratom from happy
hippo herbals.com
promo code thickboy3cs
get it try it
if you don't like it spit it out of your
mouth
okay just kidding you're gonna love it
it actually does taste good these little
these little uh liquid vials and i
continue to use it in moderation and
like it as a nootropic
and guess what don't knock it till you
try it and when you try it we're going
to do uh 20 off for life at happyhippo
herbals.com
using promo code figboi yeah that's what
you're going to do 20 off it adds up
okay
it adds up over the course of a lifetime
right
you could probably buy a house just from
using this discount code you're welcome
all right next up we've got a hella sick
fashion
segment where i'm going to talk about
oakenstone clothing because that's what
i'm wearing and that's what i wear in
every one of these episodes coming at
you and also as you may know or may not
know we are running a promo in august
whereby you cannot just only use the
code hella that i have given you to get
10 off at checkout at
oakenstoneclothing.com
you can also with that send me
proof of your purchase just a screenshot
or something like that it's in my dm all
right and if i don't get back
immediately
comment on one of my posts and i'll see
it
but you can get a free phone
consultation minimum of 20 minutes but
look i've been having these they're
going over all right because i'm
generous with my time and i want to
figure out whatever it is you got an
issue with training anabolics
diet
life advice how to grow your hair out no
seriously actually a hair restoration is
something we could talk about because i
have my own protocol i have some
alternative protocols i have some
experience i have some advice to give if
any of the things you hear me talk about
interest you more or you just like to
get to know me
buy some from openstone send me the
proof of purchase and we will get on the
phone in the month of august i promise
remember use code hella or did the
purchase even happen i don't know
you're gonna like the shirts regardless
all right let's get on to bro science
academy got an interesting one for us
today now this clip from the andrew
huberman channel is talking about
all-cause mortality
and
the best exercises for overall health
and longevity with dr peter attaya now
this is an interesting topic for me
because a lot of people go you know
you're a bodybuilder and i bristle at
that because i go no i work out to look
good i'm not a bodybuilder i work out
also to feel good and for long-term
health like there is a mixture of those
things going on yes i'm immediately
concerned about like you know i want to
be in shape versus out of shape i don't
think i'm taking that to any sort of
extreme like i've again
reframed my uh you know obsession on a
certain appearance or performance which
i had more of when i was
in my teens and twenties playing
football so it was just much more
immediate to be like i need to be a
certain weight i need to be a certain
strength
now i do think about how what wants to
you know how i want to be when i'm in my
50s my 60s i still want to be strong i
still want to be you know in good
cardiovascular health because i know
that's not just going to extend my
lifespan that's also
going to extend my health span which is
something that rhonda patrick talks
about you know towards the end of your
life sure you're live to 100 what if the
last 30 years of your life
is terrible because
every day you're in pain you can't do
normal things you know you're so weak
that you have to
ride around at a rascal suitor
you're so weak that you have to ride
around with a rascal scooter
scooter
all over walmart
um
your tongue's so weak you can't
pronounce basic words
this sounds like a terrible position to
be in in life
so i think about this and it's also
stuff that i want to pass this on to my
mom and go hey here's stuff you can do
or here's how we can sort of measure
that and it's pretty tremendous
when you look at certain things
the first thing i'm going to say is
having
muscle mass and specifically strength is
one of the biggest indicators of a drop
in all cosmortal when you look at people
who are strong for their
age and gender and not strong there's
huge differences between all cause
mortality why is that i don't know
exactly but i have to imagine it has
something to do with
resilience right and
there's more ways to die when you're too
weak to support yourself or get up and
down safely you can fall downstairs more
you know your body is just less
acclimated to
general stress even right as somebody
who trains with weights your body's used
to
undergoing stress and recovering from
that at appropriate levels
you saw that in covet right cova
distressed your body
and
some people aren't equipped to deal with
that especially if you're obese you
don't work out all these other things so
i go yeah man i want to be surviving
those
threats to my livelihood by giving
myself appropriate doses of stress that
i can control
and so they measure these things like
hey if you're 40 years old you know you
want to be able to dead hang for two
minutes you want to be able to do an air
squat for two minutes you want to have a
certain vo2 max based on
your age that even if you can't measure
it maybe you're looking at a standard
that approximates that like oh you can
run a mile in six minutes you know
it's not exact but you can approximate
like you're if you're if you can run a
mile and under this time or you know
this is your specific max mile time or
lowest mile time that gives you an idea
of the vo2 max
the bottom 25 percent
to 50 to 70 percent
um let me say that again the bottom 25
when it comes to vo2 max per age group
right the worst quarter
the the people who have the lowest vo2
max per their age versus the 50th
percentile to the 70th percentile which
is this the 20 that's above the very
middle
there is a 2x difference in all-cause
mortality so you're twice as likely to
die even you know or you're 100 more
likely to live
just being
above the median right
not elite just above the median and then
the bottom 25 percent
uh to the top two percent is a 5x
difference in all-cause mortality
and that's considered elite right two
percent but that's not that it's not
like you're going oh elite marathon
runners it's like if you do a marathons
you're probably elite as far as your vo2
max
you know you just have to be better than
98 people out of a hundred as far as
your cardiovascular health your vo2 max
which is not that hard to do um you know
if you have a pretty decent times or you
train at that all the time it's
achievable and that creates a difference
of 5x or 400 percent difference right
you're dying that much less
being in good cardiovascular health
than the people
a vast swath of people at the bottom the
bottom quarter not even the bottom 2
versus the top two percent it's the
bottom quarter versus the two percent so
it's a huge difference right and it's a
reason to stay in shape and i was you
know i talked to bradley martin this
morning we're talking about running and
we're doing the tough mudder coming up
and i was like oh yeah well i normally
you know during the pandemic i was
running like six miles a day and you
know four mile hill runs and he was like
what you know and i'm like i was a
little bit lighter but still i think
bodybuilders
um
because it's uncomfortable to run they
just don't want to get good at it you
know bradley martin told me he had pain
and his achilles and i get that he's
heavier than me you know and a little
bit shorter so he has a lot more muscle
than me it is uncomfortable but
you should do it right casey no runs 10
miles a day true or not
not
but i can if i want right no actually
that's a good case study because it's a
good casey study
because he did actually beat everyone at
thick boy in uh the thick mudder so buy
a lot buy a lot right so it goes to show
you you have that you got that vo2 max
on tap right
preach i mean what's up dude it's like
not to brag or whatever but
a smoke jaw
let's check out that six minute mark
let's see what he says those are
enormous positive effects of
cardiovascular exercise uh far greater
than the sorts of numbers that i see
around
let's just say supplement a or something
and that's you know like this is my
whole pet peeve in life right it's like
i just can't get enough of the
machinating and arguing about this
supplement versus that supplement
and
i feel like you shouldn't be having
those arguments until you have your
exercise house in order
um you know you shouldn't be arguing
about
your
this nuance of your carnivore diet
versus this nuance of your paleo diet
versus this nuance of your vegan diet
like
until you can dead lift your body weight
for 10 reps like then then you can come
and talk about those things or something
like let's just come up with some
metrics like until your vo2 max is at
least to the 75th percentile and you're
able to dead hang for at least a minute
and you're able to wall sit for at least
two like we could rattle off a bunch of
relatively low hanging fruit i wish
there was a rule that said like you
couldn't talk about anything else
i will stop it there so i thought that
was a really good point because so many
questions
i rarely get questions on the nuance of
train i do
but people
aren't normally coming to me like
you know hey my hand position on the
bench presser this angle that i'm
pushing up and that's what i find that i
teach people in person like if you were
to actually
train with me in person i find that i'm
making more micro adjustments on you
know you think you're doing this right
or optimally
not that i know everything about
everything but i find that people it's
like oh right you need you know small
tweaks in this area
but
people don't come to me with this that's
the most common thing i like end up
doing in real life but people come to me
with what pre-workout do you use
what do you think about creatine what
steroids should i take
and
i'm always tempted to have these
conversations
pre-workout probably being the least
interesting one of all of those because
i think you should basically be able to
train in your sleep if you need to like
you should be able to train
while tired while lethargic while
yawning like you know not feeling
jittery from
you know taking
methamphetamine adjacent to pre-workout
shouldn't be the thing that prevents you
from doing bench press you know i just
don't like it's nice to like feel up and
motivated because like that that's what
you're gonna do for the rest of your
life is like be like man if i'm not
sweating out of my ass cheeks i can't do
dead lifts today
learn to just do it regardless that's
the most important thing and then save
it for when you really need that extra
you know a bit of motivation or whatever
you think you're getting from
pre-workout i just
you know take anadra honestly
like
that's the best pre-workout anabolic
steroids that hit your body within a
matter of hours because they are
uh you know methylated oral steroids cut
that out no don't but seriously it's
like i'm like why not just you know if
you need something that bad like go all
the way i but
what they're talking about here is like
on the hierarchy of
things to get in shape supplements are
you know
that's at the very top
which means that every other layer has
to be in order and training is at the
very bottom right
training rest diet if you don't know how
to work out if you're not doing it
properly
if you're not focused on these things
you're not going to get good results and
i've just noticed that over time i've
always talked to people who are like
fixating on their supplements or asking
about creatine and it's like
you don't even know how to do a pull-up
you don't even know you know and i catch
her somewhere it's going you don't even
know how to do a muscle up oh
[Music]
imaginary slam
but i just love that it was like you
shouldn't be able to ask or talk about
anything else until you have your
training house in order get your
training house in order to spend much to
spend ten times as much thinking about
your training
as you do in your supplementation you
know
eat healthy foods in general get a lot
of protein that takes care of ninety
percent of your diet you know what i
mean it's really not that hard there are
a lot of options
you know if you want to lose a lot of
body fat sure it requires more
fine-tuning but like
you know you're probably not training
hard enough if you think that like a
supplement is going to be the thing that
gets you all those results you're not
trading hard enough
what do we have next i don't know oh my
god hella chef harlow we haven't talked
about
hella chef
related topics lately and i just wanted
to come in real quick and drop some
zucchini pasta knowledge on y'all this
is something that look i'm not a pasta
guy
i don't sit around fantasize about pasta
with it some people do even though i did
i
grew up eating italian food cooked by my
irish grandma
who cooked for her italian husband who
was very demanding and very critical of
the recipes that she would throw
together so look she learned
because if not you know what i'm saying
he would clap his hands like this and
you don't want to get the reverse clap
does it mean anything beyond this yeah
because it doesn't sound right this is
like oh what is that you know yeah
that's bad fettuccine alfredo yeah this
is kind of muted but this is the way
this is yeah that's the clap you want to
get so
you know
you messed up the chicken parmigiana
for mario my grandpa now um
so
pasta's like i don't get it like it's
not worth it like splurging carbs on to
me um but i remember i was introduced to
vegetable pasta i'm like oh damn this is
like the diet coke of pastas because
casey's like timeout brother i am i'm
trying to fight myself
i'm going to bite my tongue here i'm
going to let you finish i can't go ahead
go ahead casey casey chime in on pasta
to say that zucchini pasta is to pasta
as diet coke is to coke is [ __ ]
blasphemous and i hate you
diet coke is better than coke okay diet
coke is so good yeah diet coke is
phenomenal zucchini pasta it's tolerable
but it's not
i don't eat it and go oh this is like
pasta it's a different thing it's
vegetable you put sauce on it texturally
okay there's some
cross over there but other than that i
mean it's not the diet coke
you know what actually
it's anything
maybe like lentil pasta is the diet coke
of pasta i agree with you in the sense
that because this is an unpopular
opinion so i'm going like i'm gonna
couch this but my extremist diet coke
views align with yours diet coke is in
fact better it's like yeah i've been
drinking diet coke for so long and you
know i can eat 12 of them if i want to
and it's still zero calories and i don't
care how much splenda is sitting in my
guts right now
you know and there's actually i mean
we've been over this but there's no
evidence that like you know splint is
going to ruin your life any time soon
but i agree with you that i love diet
coke
and what you said where it's like it's a
it's a tolerable
uh analog or replacement for regular
pasta that to me is worth the trade you
know because
when you go from 200 plus calories per
cup down to 20 right or 30 hours just
looking this up 38 grams of carbs in a
cup of pasta versus three grams of carbs
for zucchini and it's kind of like
you're getting that effect if you're not
eating carbs all the time what do you
need all this a bowl of pasta for i
don't get it you know so i remember any
time i've had
zucchini or carrot or whatever squash
pasta i'm like
this kind of scratches whatever itch i
thought i had right as not being a pasta
fanatic but i don't know maybe if you
suffer from pasta addiction you can work
in some zucchini pasta for yourself
and send in a video telling me how i
saved your life
that's all that i got for
hella chef harley today help i'm on
steroids
i wanted to have a brief recap of a
conversation that i had with a guy who
took advantage yes people are taking
advantage of my oak and stone offer
you buy a shirt in the month of august
or you buy anything from the website and
i will get on the phone with you
we'll figure out a time that works for
you we'll do a 20 minute plus phone
consultation now i ended up talking to
this guy for 40 minutes i don't mind
that because you know i'm here and there
i'll schedule it in a time where it's
not going to be a hard out that i have
oh my god 20 minutes is up click
you know we're also going gonna catch up
i'm gonna see what's up with you before
we get into any serious questions i
might have he had some questions about
trt some of the basics um you know how
to backload an insulin syringe he was
using these big harpoons in his shoulder
and he's like man i'm you know i feel
like i might be getting some scar tissue
or some stuff's happening there it was a
little painful i'm like yeah backload
those 29 gauge insulin syringes you can
buy them off amazon is one thing
secondly he was asked he's kind of had a
similar background to me where he took
some larger cycles before and this is
kind of what i did in college had a few
cycles with a number of compounds
you know went off for a very long time
and then came back on to a trt dose he's
asking me can i bump it up from 150 up
to 200 to 250 you know what's
what should i do somebody else is
recommending that i go up to
you know
600 tests i'm like i don't think you
need to do that even though
people always do that oh you should go
up here will it work for you maybe or
you feel like you need that because
maybe you're not training that hard or
whatever people always tell me to do
more
and i think for most people it's just
not needed until you max out what you
got at that dose so
i introduced him to this principle that
i believe came from russia but it's has
to do with
you find a dose of tests that you can do
without an ai an aromatase inhibitor or
a selective estrogen receptor modulator
a serum such as tamoxifen or novidex you
find that dosa test well
no issues okay you find that dosa test
that
you're going to tolerate that's not
going to give you estrogenic side
effects that's not going to bloat you
too much and you can run with that right
because
you know keep cranking up that test but
you also have to take another toxic
compound in anastrozole it's not ideal
right
and you do want some estrogen you just
want it to be
an ideal amount not too low not too high
um
and
you know that was
the bulk of the conversation just giving
him some nuances and kind of making him
feel a better and and introducing to the
idea of like blasting and cruising even
just on test right because you can go up
to like i'm gonna go up to three or four
hundred a week
and then come back down to a trt dose
and then bump it up
aligning with harder training blocks
right that's the thing it's like you
push when your doses are a little bit
higher for six to eight weeks then you
come back for a month
maybe also run hcg clomid do a pct which
you can do on a trt dose and it's still
going to be effective rather than going
you know guys are like i want to do a
cycle of test and then come off
completely i'm like but why you know why
would you want to crash yourself and to
truly get off of it it's months you're
going to backslide you're not going to
feel great and test is just not that
toxic to actually require that time time
off like you would from orals
the other thing that you asked that i
thought was very important is
can you get a girl pregnant on trt
there's a lot of
information out there
you know that
i would say bro science mostly or rumors
or misinformation that
the moment you inject anything in your
body it like shuts down
your sperm production to the point that
you're infertile not true
now it may reduce it
but if you are running hcg for example
on trt
you're probably going to be good so
there's you know guys talk to me about
oh i went completely off in order to
have a kid i don't think that's
necessary so i would at least get
yourself checked first because i know
for a fact it is possible i've gotten
several women pregnant while on trt just
kidding don't clip that but uh i know
for a fact it is possible so
if that's something that's
your major hang up from
getting on juice guess what we just
cleared the way for you
time to take off
to juiceville usa
and we can finally
get down to some this is why we can't
have nice gyms
everyone's favorite segment what are we
looking at here oh yeah mom uh this is a
text from mom
i'm gonna have to let it reload again to
see i found a bag of creatine steroid
powder in your bedroom i'm extremely
disappointed in you
get home now
and then uh the dude's running me
running home before she finds the actual
steroids i am somebody whose parents
actually found their steroids
uh
you know not once but multiple times
and let me tell you the panic is real
and also trying to explain this look i
turned out fine i knew what i was doing
that's debatable but
in a parent's head like i remember being
on the phone with my dad
and
in this particular incident i had
gotten a mail order something it was
like for me and some other people who
were doing it but you know of course i
was the conduit for all this
uh
like
they were supposed to hold but i was
staying at the college over the summer
to do a job and they forwarded my mail
to my parents so my dad gets his package
from me
and of course they're nosy as [ __ ] so
they open it up and find all these
steroids
and my dad calls me it's like well first
actually i got a warning for my little
brother who's like dude this is on the
way like just wanted to you know like
the nuclear bomb is coming you have 20
minutes to prepare i was like thank you
i was like is there any way you can just
go grab it out of his hands right now
but he calls me up and you know we had a
heart to heart he ends up crying and
it just it felt so bad to me because i'm
like he was like you know said something
to the effect of look i just i can't
lose you you know i'm not gonna like do
a shitty imitation of my dad's crying
voice but um
he was very emotional because in his
mind he thought i was going to die from
this you know what i mean and i remember
a buddy of mine that i also got this for
his he was his his parents were strict
indian parents like from india and they
found this under his bed they found
little insulin syringes and they're like
oh my god our son's a drought i got a
drug out of doing heroin you know it was
like the most in even no no it's just
equipoise you know it doesn't matter um
it's very hard to talk parents back down
from that so that just reminded me of
that like absolute panic where you're
just like oh my god this is like the
worst like
not only are the the compounds you know
gone now and flushed down the toilet but
i have to convince my parents that i'm
not a drug addict who's going to die any
minute you know
from
sudden cardiac arrest from taking deca
oh
parents are so lame
i take a picture every day since i
started go to the gym i love these
things where the guys like
because obviously all he's doing is
pushing out a stomach and starting to
flex by the end of it while doing all
that
um
and that just goes to show like
like we saw jesse james west over there
always couch everything i look at with
like yes perfect lighting
perfect whatever even for that day if
you get dehydrated all these little
factors go into your appearance don't be
fooled on social media
um
don't you know look at somebody's
physique and think oh my god i'm looking
in the mirror you know somebody caught
me off guard and you know i'm always
doing this like my stomach's out it's
like oh i look way i like 20 pounds
fatter when my stomach is distended
because i just let it relax you know
don't be fooled by social media because
the right lighting the right body oil
it can all make a huge difference what
do we got next
pov you have to travel but it was leg
day yesterday
eddie hall is going around in a instead
of wheeled down it's just like an office
chair right this is how i felt last week
i was sore for over seven days i got i
did my eight sets of 20 on leg press and
with a final set of 50 at the end it's
too much it's stupid i don't think
anybody should do that that's why i
recommend doing a few sets a day for
legs because i was sore for eight whole
days
all right what do we got now we got a
another stupid-ass leg press where he's
taking oh this looks like a third world
country gym based on all the shitty
plates
but there's like 30 plates on this leg
press
like but how much can you squat
i bet you can't even rep 405 astrograss
he's doing less than a quarter squat and
it's just embarrassing why
look if you did all that yourself i'd
almost have no problem with it but what
these guys always do
is incorporate every single person in
the gym and that's what i find
humiliating and that's what i always
rubs me the wrong way about these
narcissistic activities is like you
couldn't just do it for yourself you had
to like
hire
everybody around you to participate in
this delusion
story of my life right
um let's see
this i found pretty interesting because
it's i'll just play it
here's chris hemsworth playing four in
the new movie
see an issue
they aren't the same person they don't
have the same physique cgi has changed
the game they not only can you fight
dragons or flight into space but you now
also can look even more jacked than you
do in real life both natalie portman and
chris hemsworth in this movie were cgi
altered to look more technical okay i
think that's that's about enough so his
main point is
we've seen chris hemsworth in real life
we seem to walk around we see what his
workouts are we've seen the shitty
fitness app that he's trying to sell you
and uh pretend like he's not on steroids
nor is his trainer despite gaining 20
pounds of muscle in five weeks and
dropping down to five percent body fat
for 15 but he's definitely natural and
it's definitely just for flipping tires
and doing uh lunges with kettlebells
right and some mountain climbers thrown
in there too
everything about this is a lie his
training his diet his anabolic use um
surprise surprise special effects from
hollywood but it just it doesn't even
stop with that it's like you're taking
steroids
and you're still using cgi to make you
look even buffer and i think the average
person just wouldn't piece that together
they look at him and go oh my god look
at that amazing unattainable physique
you know he's somehow
just inherently superior to me but then
you find out it's like oh no he added
three inches to his arms and shoulders
from cgi and that's why you just
you can't believe anything you see in
hollywood in
social media
you know really
anything that you see online or in video
is
probably going to be fake
there's one exception to that
and i think you know where i'm going
with this that's right
the only person who never edits their
photos
who pathologically
refuses to do any sort of cgi to his
body even though every week casey goes
we could cgi this you could look buffer
and i go
nope
i think this is fine
i think i'm buff enough i think i've got
this dude i think my lat spread's gonna
block out the sun
sinking just like the sun
that's called a lat set